and a demolition company giving the
ultimate gift to a mom of a
three-year-old boy who died in a mobile
home fire that was back in december the
company footing the entire bill to get
her charred mobile home torn down in
order for a new one to be put in
victoria saha has been covering this
tragedy since the very beginning and she
has a story
what was once a home filled with so many
memories
now turned to rubble it was the home
rhian machum shared with her two
daughters and three-year-old son kaiden
until an early morning fire in december
took kaiden's life
just pulls at your heart strings right
away owner of trusted demolition susan
claussen is helping the meacham family
get a fresh start doing a six thousand
dollar demolition for free there's
nothing more tragic than losing a child
and i have two kids myself it was just
the right thing to do ever since that
tragic fire machine was here every
single day taking down this mobile home
piece by piece all by herself that's
because her home was unsalvageable and
her insurance company wasn't responding
right away she was also dealing with
thieves breaking in and taking what was
left of cayden's toys getting cut and
scraped and breathing in
dust and
everything from the fire
magem's mom tammy kenno stepped in
calling around different demolition
companies until trusted demolition
responded
the godsend they don't even know us can
i give you a hug macho was able to thank
the company herself on tuesday i would
have been out here for a lot of months
trying to do it by hand a six-month
ordeal finally coming to an end showing
us there is hope after tragedy victoria
zaha live local now
now once the lot is clear it will make
room for a new mobile home the family
hopes to have that done by july